Thanks so it is kind of a fun meta
experience cuz it just told some people
to film here but like my dad lives two
blocks away from here and I will say
it's been a really meta experience to
wake up in your dad's house with like it
was kind of like I was back in 16 when I
was 16 but now like there's a PI data in
Eindhoven and it's like envelope and I
can bike to just it's been fun
we I kind of want to talk about is how
to prevent miles of scrolling and how to
reduce the spaghetti code from the
copypasta because I've been teaching
Python for a while I've been doing this
data stuff for a bit but I've always
seen people sort of like treat these
notebooks as if they're junk food and I
figured I call it untitled 12 that I PI
and B but let's be honest most companies
you know they they reach like 20 you
know 42 or some arbitrarily large number
like we've seen is untitled 12th
phenomenon happen and and the thing is
there's actually kind of a way of sort
of approaching code that will sort of
make those problems go away
because I think a lot of people might
have a way of working that can
definitely be improved and I just want
to show you like a really quick hack to
sort of show from solve most problems
after that I just want to briefly point
out the generality of it it's not just
pandas and notebooks that we can fix
with this attitude is actually a whole
bunch of things and then I kind of want
to maybe touch upon how to learn how to
get there but but the first thing is
like workflow really matters and I
remember this little data science thing
started like in 2012 or something I
remember having to go to companies to
explain why we don't like to use Excel
for our analyses usually we like to use
other tools and there's a couple of
reasons for it so one of the main
reasons of not using Excel one of the
reasons why I think it sucks is we want
to separate the data from the analysis
one of the really really painful bits of
doing analysis with Excel is that it's
really hard to figure out if that cell
is like calculated or if it's actually
raw data you don't necessarily have that
in an overview and that's sort of a
source for errors another thing that I
didn't much like about Excel is it was
kind of hard to automate the analysis so
you have to sort of you get a new data
sitting and again you kind of have to do
the manual tweaking and you know that
doesn't really feel like you're a proper
IT person when you
do everything by hand all the time and
the other thing I didn't really like
about it is that the analysis wasn't
really but producible if someone had an
excel file mainly because the data
analysis weren't sort of separated but
it's really hard to reproduce some Excel
analysis it's someone else made it's
really hard to add proper documentation
to it and this is kind of a the last one
was kind of like a personal concern but
I think we should not pay a third-party
obscene amounts of money for something
as basic as arithmetic and I really
think the budget is better spent if you
allocate it towards education of staff
or like an office party or whatever
innovation I really think that in 2019
we should not pay a third party to do
this and I also think that Excel is
still sort of around I think too many
analyses are still done with Excel and I
actually think it's kind of frightening
an insurance company depends on the
floating-point arithmetic of an expels
Excel spreadsheet and to make sure there
are pension plans are being Korea
calculated correctly and frankly I think
that's kind of frightening a lot of this
thankfully is changing now that we have
tools like pandas and Jupiter so that's
good
but if I'm being very honest if I look
at how most people use a notebook and
how they use pandas have we actually
solved all of those four points is every
notebook really separating today this
like the data from the analysis and is
it's super automatable and is our
analysis reproducible I mean I guess
we've solved part four but I think for a
lot of analyses we probably haven't
really consciously touched upon the
first three things so what I figure it
might be fun and I'll just show you how
I think most people start with a
notebook and how they do an analysis so
I'll just do some live coding here and
hopefully after five minutes of live
coding
we'll have seen many things that have
gone wrong probably because I don't have
the right attitude of approaching a
notebook and so people say don't do live
coding during a talk and I'm just gonna
totally ignore that advice so um here is
a Jupiter lab instance and there's a
notebook called untitled 12 I imported
numpy I've imported pandas and I've
imported the math 12 Lib and I have this
data set that I'll be playing with
just want to show you a really cool
feature that you have a that you have
nowadays actually so what you can do you
can click this plus symbol in a new
version of Jupiter lab and besides the
terminal which is great to have in there
there's a new feature called a
contextual helper and a contextual
helper is badass what you can do is you
can just have contextual help here and
if your cursor is let's just run this
and the idea being that are this has to
run okay load a load if your cursor is
over a function from any sort of package
that has a doc string what the
contextual helper will do is it will
just sort of show you the documentation
on whatever thing your cursor is over so
no need to do the question mark in front
of the function name anymore as long as
you have the contextual helper there
that's your helper right there and I
would love to use it like in this case
but I can tap on the zoom in so I'm
gonna close it up but probably one of
the first things that people don't
really do much is just appreciate all
the features that Jupiter has maybe
taking a step back and just appreciating
some of these extra things that you can
use is also the thing that's gonna help
you a bit
especially the contextual helper this
thing is like badass it totally changed
the way I work what I mean
analysis that's what I want to talk
about so this is one of my favorite
datasets it's from World of Warcraft you
might have heard of this videogame the
idea is that you have a character ID
this character was a level 1 orc
rogue it's super serious analysis and
the this level 1 or Grogg was apparently
in Orgrimmar which i think is the
capital of orc country and this person
was around at a certain time stamp and
we can see if the person was or was not
part of a guild and the guild is
basically a bunch of people that slay
dragons together but you're in the guild
or not and one thing I thought was
interesting about this data set is the
way it works is every time that you're
logged in there's sort of this heartbeat
in a system so every 10 minutes if
you're still playing the game there's
going to be another row of data so that
means that I can see how long a person
is playing the video game and I can
therefore calculate how long it takes
they get to level 60 right so I can sort
of calculate how much human time has
been wasted on this
so that feels like a fun analysis but so
in order to sort of play with that one
thing I probably want to do is I want to
sort of group by the character and then
what I kind of want to do is I want to
sort of well I don't want to assign this
but I want to aggregate this and one
thing I probably want to calculate is
just a number of rows and I'll just take
the level column and I can just say I
want the n peanut-sized function to work
on that doesn't work level doesn't exist
hmm why is that let's look at the f I
think level does exist but the way panas
works is you can have a space in your
column name but no worry what I'll just
do is I'll just fix that so I'll just do
a C don't replace I'll replace the space
with I don't know nothing and then for C
in DF don't columns I'll just do
something like this okay this is super
clear to everyone great
and so what I'll now do is I'll put
brackets around this and I have the
number of rows we're just kind of cool
what I'll do next is I'll just calculate
the min level so that's the level and
I'll calculate the NPL min of that and
what I'll do next is I'll calculate the
maximum level so that's level and then
max so that's also kind of good and I
think what I probably also want to have
is I want to have if you're part of a
guild I need to sort of summarize that
in some way and I kind of glanced over
it but as you can see in this data set
you can have like a minus one and your
guild which basically indicates you're
not in a guild so what's let's touch on
that so I'll just do your guild is I
don't know like your guilt thing and
then P don't max and then I'll and I
have a bunch of statistics here for the
characters and then the whatnot so what
I'll just do this is a nice little
intermediate result so I'll just call
this D f2 and then I'll move on I think
we can see where this is going right
because I probably need some other data
set as well because what I kind of want
to do now maybe is that I sort of think
to myself like you know what I kind of
need if I if I want to do research and
what the effects of the guild is what I
probably need to have is I probably also
want to have you know how many people
are in the guild I think if you're
small guild as opposed to like a big
deal them probably that might have an
effect on how you're leveling right so I
don't just want to have df2 I want to
have TF three as well and in that case
what I just got to do is I got a group
by the guild and then I just do this one
aggregation and I'll do something like I
know a number of characters is equal to
I'm counting yes I think what I got to
do here is just do character and then
number of unique I think as a string
should do this and it's waiting a bit
but alright yeah and so the most people
are not in the guild but a bunch of
people are and then what I got to do is
I got a sort of I kind of want to join
this data set back up to that data set
so probably gonna do is like df3 don't
reset index and then what I got to do is
I got a call df2 that merge right so
what I have now is I sort of know the
guild number and I know how many people
are in that guild and business sort of
now combined and I get to increase this
guy with another number which is great
and at this point what you can sort of
do is you can sort of say you know what
I'll do is I'll just make a sort of a
plot out of this so one thing that I I
can sort of do maybe is I think my full
Lib is on so I can do like a plot and I
can say scatter and I can say D f4 and
then I can do something like you know
what I want to do is want to check the
number of rows and I kind of want to
check what the max level is then I
suppose that might be something that's
interesting to see right so the more
someone has been playing the higher that
max level is all right and I guess
that's kind of cool but I'm actually a
little bit more interested in sort of
the level increase I think right that
might be better so what I can do is I go
to D f4 and I can do something like max
level and then minus DF 4 min level I
think something like that and what I can
do now is I can sort of you know even
though this operation is actually
supposed to go maybe in between here but
that's not how the world works cuz I'm
thinking out loud and then typing so I'm
gonna keep this line here
but now I can sort of say hey here
there's a level increase good nice now
so timeout here
bunch of stuff that will go wrong
suppose that I show this to someone I
mean for starters is probably the person
who has access to this notebook doesn't
have a folder called users Vincent's
downloads right so that already is kind
of an issue and and what's more is if I
now were to share this with people I'm
creating the variable name under the
chart that needs it and that's not even
talking about all this df4 nonsense but
the thing is I'm kind of looking at all
of your faces I think a lot of people
recognize that this is sort of a flow
that everyone is using while making a
notebook and I get it right so if you're
doing this like you're sort of in the
zone and and hey I kind of understand
his dataset now some on fire so I want
to keep on doing the coding and stuff
but then that and I get that feeling
that you want to sort of really dig deep
and like dive into the rabbit hole but
maybe that's a dangerous thing to do
probably if I'm going to do like a
primary analysis and then I have found a
conclusion that might be interesting but
I kind of want to be sure that I clusion
conclusion is at least correct and I
kind of want to make a system that's
very easy to iterate on that I can
actually share with my colleagues so so
so this way if coding it's not gonna
work cuz you're gonna end up having to
rewrite this and that's not effective
and you know I'm sure that we kind of
agree if I continue on this path I will
end up with a notebook where I can
scroll for them for miles and miles as
well all right which is also kind of a
painful thing so what I'm gonna do now
instead is kind of come up with it with
a better notebook I'm just gonna start
by saying how about I just call this
notebook what it is whoa
churn analysis or something just give
the notebook a name and I guess what
I'll just go ahead and do is I'll just
you know take that code and I'll take
this code and sort of use this as a
starting point and now sort of think
about stuff that I could be doing okay
so the datasets loaded and I mean one
thing that I could for example do
like typically when you start out with a
with a dataset like this I mean if I
think about all the steps that are
happening here technically this is
changing the columns thing that sounds
like I'm cleaning the data right and if
I think about most analyses it's
probably usually kind of like always
this sort of phase where you're cleaning
your data set up so how about I just
give them a name right so I'll just make
a function called clean data set and
some data frame will go in there and
then I'll in this case I'll just return
that data frame I mean that that that
can be fine and then you know one thing
that I could then do is I can also think
of hey what are some other things that I
typically want to do well that's
probably a face called remove outliers
also probably a phase that you're gonna
do and I could kind of imagine that the
way that I remove outliers there might
be parameters for that and the function
kind of allows for that that's kind of
nice but then at least all the logic on
how to remove outliers is kind of
contained because if I look at this the
problem here is not so much that this
code doesn't work but it's that I don't
have an overview that Here I am
aggregating and here I'm adding features
so to say it might be nicer if I have a
function that says add features and that
way when I look back at it I know ah
anywhere where there's features being
added it should happen in that function
that makes it a lot easier to the bug
the only downside is that you we're not
kind of there yet but like one thing
that might happen is that you do
something like remove outliers clean
data set and then you put your data
frame in there like this and this is
kind of hard to read right so the
downside of this is you can't have to
read from the inside all the way back
out to the outside
luckily panas was looking at how the our
language deals with this and they kind
of made this cool trick so what you can
do these days is you can just say data
frame dealt pipe and then give that to
this function and in this case I'm going
to give it to the clean data set
function first and then to the remove
outliers and the idea is that you take
the data frame it will then be given to
the clean data set function and it will
then be given to the remove out
function okay there's a couple of things
that I really like about this for
starters I don't have to think about the
logic of my analysis whatsoever but I
can already write this down and this
already gives me kind of a framework of
mind it gives me a bit of calm and this
is sort of a great starting point for me
to sort of fill in the blanks and also
as you can probably imagine if I'm
increasing and increasing my analysis as
long as I can sort of figure out do I
need to have a new step here or does
this action I want to do can I put that
in another step that to my mind makes it
much easier not only to do the analysis
not only to iterate on the analysis but
it also makes it a lot easier to
maintain there is a trap though and I
kind of miss it it's a Python thing but
I just kinda want to show you but but I
hope we kind of like this idea it gives
us more of an overview like that feeling
is good that's very important but let's
now let's suppose now I implement this
clean data set function right so what I
can do is I can say data Affleck columns
equals and then I can do see dolt
replace for C in data F something like
this right and then what I could do just
to just to clarify I can check if the
columns that come out of this I mean
there's no space in there anymore so
it's a good thing the awkward thing
though is is that the same thing holds
for the original data frame and that
actually is a problem and we kind of saw
that happen here as well the issue kind
of is that if you're changing a data
frame as a step somewhere like you're
actively changing a property on top of a
data frame then everywhere that property
has changed so this action it would be
kind of nicer if the clean data set just
takes this data frame and it goes in
there and then the data frame that comes
out is updated without there being any
side-effects and in this particular case
a thing that I don't like and in general
it's a cause of errors is this one
function has side effects which is no
bueno one really easy way to fix that is
to just make a function called start
pipeline
and the only thing that this function
will do is it will return a copy of the
data frame and if I do this I mean I
will have to restart this of course and
now if I do this you see that the we
didn't change the column name to the
original data frame but we did change
everything in here and I can kind of
hear the troll in the audience sort of
go but ah Vincent that's super
inefficient like you know that's a screw
it I think at some point you can stairs
have blind to this concept of efficient
efficient see but what I hope to show
you here is screw efficiency this is
more effective I really think it's okay
it is like waste like 10 seconds of
compute power maybe if that means it in
the long run I don't have to spend hours
maintaining it
so as you're writing this code maybe
also the attitude here should not be hey
I'm focused on performance maybe what
I'm trying to do here is and just trying
to explain the recipe what I'm doing
here is I'm basically I'm making a
cookbook this is the recipe for the
analysis that I kind of want to do and
what I'm cooking a chicken well I don't
cook chickens cuz I'm vegetarian but if
I'm cooking a chicken I tend to care
more about flavor than the speed at
which the dish can go out to my family
right I think it's a better attitude to
have but there's a bonus with this as
well so I hope that we sort of
experience this sort of calm of mind
kind of thing but it's actually the
little bonus that we can do too so one
thing we could do is because all of
these things here are functions there's
actually an extra trick that we are able
to do so I will make a badly spelled
function here up here called log and I
think we heard of decorators before
right so yes some of you have so the
idea with a decorator is it is a
function that accepts a function and
returns a function it's really
functional here's how it works what you
can do is you can say hey I have this
this wrapper that's sort of on the
inside and let's let's just have a
function we're gonna declare a function
in here that will accept a data frame as
its first argument and then it gets
arguments and keyword arguments and
let's then also which is
like import daytime as DT because gonna
do something with timing how long this
takes
and one thing that I could do is I could
do something like okay we have a tick
moment that is the DT day time but now
and then we have a talk moment which is
a DT of day time dot now all I can do is
I can say hey there's a result which is
essentially this one function that goes
in and I'm giving it the data the
arguments and the keyword arguments and
I will return the results now but before
I do that I will actually print an F
string saying I can sort of say F dunder
name this is the name of the function
took and I can do something like talk -
tick and then every time I have a
function that accepts a data frame and
outputs a data frame then I sort of have
a nice little decorator here that might
be able to do some logging so what I can
do is I do wrap for a return wrapper
here a kind of cool thing now is I can
say hey let's add this decorator to all
of these functions right
and let's not also do this and let's
like let's call this clean DF so it
comes out of here
if it didn't make a coding error a kind
of a nice thing that we get for free
here is that if we have a function here
that's kind of like nice in general then
we kind of get logging for free I don't
know about you but I like stuff that's
free because now I get to think hey
what's important for me to log here and
in particular one thing that I can
imagine for this you know a particular
use case I'll be removing outliers right
so one thing that's probably important
for this particular analysis is that I
keep track not just of the shape of the
data frame but also the number of
characters that are still in here so
don't just care about the rows if at
some point I have an analysis and I only
have like 100 characters left not
another mine and a little power has sort
of decreased so one thing I could go
ahead and do is I can sort of do
something with this result and I can do
something like shape equals and I can do
like the results don't shape unless
that's at that so this is shape there as
well but one thing I can kind of do is I
can sort of say okay it took equals but
I should probably also be able to say
hmm what's the nicest way of doing this
I guess I could do result up grouped by
car egg and then I could do something
like and car equals no car and peanuts
sighs and I think if I get the shape at
this gap is like in characters sort of I
think that's a tough ball but I know
right okay so don't actually do and
Charro's zero but I hope you catch the
drift I'm able to add logging features
that are important to my analysis but
here's the epic thing now suppose as
luck might have it that this analysis is
something will actually go to production
notice that we've just fixed logging and
also just an extra bonus suppose now at
some point that these functions are well
written and well defined what I could
even do this is amazing feature of
Python you can make a file you can call
it common the PI you could put that
stuff in here and that it could import
it and that's important and the reason
for that is is that means that we can
now use the notebook as a scratch pad
but the moment that the function is sort
of mature enough that we can remove it
from the notebook such as the notebook
then becomes the summary it becomes a
user interface it becomes a place where
we can sort of very quickly make nice
little charts instead of it having to be
like the repo of all of our sort of
analytical steps and of course the next
step would be the sort of if not just
have this into common by PI but to put
this into a package right that's will be
a nice little next step you can automate
that with a cookie cutter I've
open-source mine but then also a very
very awesome thing is this is a function
you can unit test that so not only do we
sort of have this nice little way of
sort of separating the macro part of our
analysis with a micro part of our
analysis but we have a very nice way of
unit testing this so I sleep better at
night and I don't know about you but I
like having paid your duty off on a
Sunday
but also I'm just happier because I
think it's gonna be a whole lot easier
for me to sort of change the analysis if
I'm able to sort of make quick changes
on this level because a very convenient
thing is what I could do is I could say
something like hey I have a minimum
number of rows that I have Pro character
and as long as this keyword argument I
have here also exists here you know then
you can you can fiddle around on a high
level and keep the details on a low
level and therefore separates into two
different levels of abstraction which is
the whole goal of programming I'll take
questions after you would add oh you
could I guess but then you're copying a
lot right and your copy you're copying
on every single function out there
there's another reason to have to start
pipeline in here notice that suppose
that this clean data set removed a
couple of columns by having start
pipeline in here I have this one log
line that tells me how big was the data
frame before we got started I think that
for me that's the main reason of having
a start pipeline the copying thing is
nice it's a cool security mechanism but
I like having that one log line because
if it didn't have that start pipeline
function the second line of the logs
will not show me the original size so
it's a good is a cool idea but I kind of
prefer this so I can imagine and this is
something I've learned about teaching
understanding a decorator and
understanding a lot of these steps it
kind of takes a bit of maturity if as
far as being a Python for developer goes
I do genuinely think that if you're just
getting started and you're reading the
panas documentation you're not going to
hit this great habit probably because
you know a decorator is a relatively
advanced thing you can do in Python it's
not just a common scripting so it might
be nice if just you know there's some
easy tools here that might help you with
this so there's a package I've made
together with a bunch of lovely people
it's called psych it Lego it's a really
cool become you have stickers somewhere
but one thing we've added and this sort
of the idea like I've noticed that for
pandas and
scikit-learn there's it's not so much
that the pipeline isn't there but it's
more that sometimes you need like a
little Lego brick that you can just
click in there for your particular type
of analysis so if you're interested we
actually not only have the lock step as
a feature but we also have a tutorial on
how to get it to work with the Python
logging framework so what you can
actually do with this log step that we
have here is you can actually sort of
say hey not only do I want to log this
step but also I want to set the logging
level for this function to be different
than the logging level for this function
such that in production I'm locking
other stuff than stuff that I have in my
notebook so if I look at where we then
are I mean I think if you write the like
if you do the piping thing you will
actually just sort of for free are a lot
closer to solving the first three
problems literally you've also solved
the fourth one because it's for free but
that but but the thing is like I've sort
of noticed that if you're doing data
science and stuff don't worry too much
about the algorithm don't worry too much
about the deep learning stuff like
google has obscene amounts of compute
that you don't have so what they are
doing might not work for you different
signal okay whatever but what I hope
though is that what I've just shown you
is that if you're interested in reading
more about this everything I've just
talked about I got that from a blog from
the one of the panel's Cortes it's not
something I came up with but I kind of
want to hope that this feeling of just
clicking stuff together just note the
beauty and the generality of this I mean
you can teach this approach to the team
and then everyone can still write their
own functions their own way but at least
there is this shared principle echo
approach to code that everyone got warm
can adhere to and just that is going to
make it a whole lot easier for you to
communicate what you're doing to your
colleagues if we all just promise that
we have a clean data set phase and a
remove outlier phase and that everything
else is sort of very particular to the
to the analysis that we're doing the
only thing you got to do is come up with
a good function name that describes what
you're doing and you can and you can
actually actively focus on that and I've
actually like I've had code reviews
where we spent 10 minutes coming up with
the best name for a function and I think
there's value with that so pipelines
need Lego bricks
and I've been fortunate enough to sort
of have this experiment become a bit
successful we have about 2000 thousand
downloads a month now we are even like
it's weird if I push to pi PI I
immediately know there's the CDN
providers picking it up so after I've
made a new version within five minutes I
have 300 downloads from like all the CDN
so it's like a huge compliment there's a
couple of Dutch companies helping us out
with this and the guy from Brazil if
you're interested in this like fineness
and github we kind of we have lots of
fairness algorithms as well if you
interested in that but we kind of see
this as a very cool experiment to just
come up with hey what are some good
industry practices that don't
necessarily fit well if I could learn or
empandas but is stuff that you know I
would I would maintain it because it's
tough I want to use every day and I'm
not the only one doing it Mattias is
around there the sort is it but we are
the two main maintain errs but there's a
bunch of other people come and enjoy the
fun also just to emphasize this is why
scikit-learn is amazing right so I could
learn gives you this pipeline which sort
of automates a lot of cognitive load
away from you and the pipeline is a bit
different because this pipeline actually
requires state so that means that the
Lego bricks in this particular case are
not functions they're objects but the
whole point is that you have a pipeline
and that's the thing that's making sure
everything runs fine for me personally
this is why space is such a badass
project NLP algorithms are great but
only when they click together and for me
at least the problem that space has to
solve is just making sure we have a
convenient API or a convenient pipeline
abstraction to do NLP stuff which means
that you can bring your own Lego bricks
which is the beauty of it also it has an
amazing community like Joyner the space
he's amazing but I hope that I've kind
of demonstrated something general to all
this too because there's a great cooking
analogy if how I think most people cook
is they take the chicken they seasoned
it with spices then they season it with
gravy and then
put it in the oven I have a certain
degrees of Celsius and then they serve
it on a plate what they don't do is
serve the thing that you put in the oven
which is the thing that you season which
is the thing that code is language you
don't there's no human being who would
consider talking like this and there's
also no human being who would consider
talking like this right but if we are to
maintain something then I prefer to have
something that you can just read from
but from left to right top to bottom and
a pipe line is a really nice way to make
sure you always stick to that a pipe
line is literally this than that than
that than that so consider that code is
more like a user interface for thoughts
and it's really important to get it
right because I think if you invite
clarity and interoperability you're
gonna get a much better sort of
experience in your career it also is
what I think makes our a really nice
language so just an advice I guess I
mean maybe really don't worry about
learning the latest deep learning
technique instead invest more about
having stable code it's typically more
of a productive concern to worry about
hey how can I communicate clearly with
my colleagues then how can I use this
super complicated model I've never seen
that idea work I'd love to hear someone
say oh I tried something super complex
once and the team immediately got it to
work and it was great green fields and
rainbows it's just it what I have heard
though is hear stories of hey we
actually took two months to sort of to
really talk about how should we
communicate with each other and now we
live in a more calm environment clarity
will typically cause many improvements
in the long run and the calm that will
follow is likely going to have a greater
impact in innovation compared to yet
another library that can flow a bunch of
tensors and typically panas is a tool
that you will use daily so it feels
really weird to me that people don't
make sure they 100% master it if it's
something you use daily then it's
something that you really want to sort
of get to the bottom of and I do think
probably more time is spent in pan is
amiss I could learn if I'm honest and
it's a bit meta but and your experience
might certainly be different but I have
found it to be extremely effective to
have this calm because if you have this
sort of
calm hey nothing is on fire kind of vibe
going then it means that you can pause
and kind of reflect on how everything's
going and without this pause you cannot
really find a thing that you can improve
it doesn't give you an opportunity to
rephrase what's happening so don't go
down the rabbit hole of untitled 12
it's like haste makes waste and and it's
kind of meta but if I really just think
about it I like something drawings when
I think about stuff but I really think
that you have to reflect in the calm
moment that you are in and then you're
able to make a good investment in your
habits and the joy will just accumulate
it's it's something that will sort of
get better over time but the problem is
that most people think oh I should focus
on the habit I think you just start to
focus on the reflection just take a
moment every week look at everything
you've done and wonder is there
something that we might be able to do
better and with that I mean stuff that
I've been doing lately I kind of noticed
I have lots of these itches to scratch
but then nowadays I just don't wait for
someone else to build it I just fix it
myself so I've noticed for teaching I've
always had this weird use case that I
just want to draw a data set and then
just use it so there's this you know
thing I made it's called draw data about
X Y Z and what you're able to do is you
can just draw a bunch of points and you
can click a button that says copy CSV
copy Jason download Jason download CSV
and there's a reset button it's a free
tool go ahead and use it but scratch
your own itch but before you scratch
your own itch reflect if this is
something that you want and typically
it's a lot easier to solve the right
problem if you understand the problem
very well the future is awesome I think
the only thing we got to do is just
build it almost exactly kind of kind of
bummed out for that thanks for listening
you